so what did I do in the Marines um I was
heavy weapons when you leave depending
on how long you served and where you
served you'll get a like a resettlement
grant so basically a certain amount of
money to then go and do courses etc etc
right but I went and done like a 12we
course up in Lincoln spent six grand I
was a network and firewall engineer I
didn't realize that most of your time as
an IT engineer is you're on your own
it's cool when you're on site and you're
in the server rooms and you're switching
out routers and what firewalls and stuff
that's cool but when you're on your own
6 hours a day in on n25 listening to
radio 1 you want to BL your brains out
cuz I come from an environment where
there's 30 guys all around you all the
time you're on the shooting range you're
playing football to then just sat in a
van by myself so that was probably the
difficulty I had